j'ouvre notre second débat je vous
propose un gros plan sur la loi
immigration dont l'examen a été stoppé
victime collatérale de la crise
politique née de la réforme des
retraites que va-t-il rester d'un texte
qui se voulait équilibré entre contrôle
et intégration avant des battre un cas
d'école histoire de ceux libanais sous
le coup d'une obligation de quitter le
territoire français une qtf et donc
impossible à embaucher par son patron
boulanger à Bourg-en-Bresse cet
arpentage de Matthias Arès
depuis bientôt trois ans la famille
Homsi a quitté le Liban dans l'explosion
du port de Beyrouth Joseph Lepère a
perdu sa boulangerie un métier qu'il
pratiquait depuis 25 ans à la suite du
drame sans réfléchir la famille décide
de venir en France on est venu avec un
visa touristique
parce que
on savait pas on était sous le choc de
l'explosion vous voulez juste partir
parce qu'on était plus en sécurité le
visa expiré Joseph aiséina demande
l'asile mais son déboutés de leur
demande et se voit remettre une
obligation de quitter le territoire
français sorti des circuits d'aide de
l'État c'est grâce à la solidarité qu'il
bénéficie aujourd'hui d'un toit pour
autant la famille ne sont contente pas
déjà engagée bénévolement dans plusieurs
associations le couple clam son envie de
poursuivre son intégration par le
travail c'est pas prendre la place des
Français mais non
Joseph fait il est capable il est prêt à
travailler vraiment il est prêt à
travailler
dans son métier dans dans des
boulangeries françaises
maintenant et le père de famille est
bien décidé à y arriver depuis plusieurs
mois Joseph a une promesse d'embauche
entre les mains
ça va Joseph
Félix gérant de plusieurs boulangeries
dans l'agglomération de Bourg-en-Bresse
a beaucoup de mal à recruter depuis
plusieurs mois son annonce pour un poste
de boulanger ne trouve pas preneur alors
quand le père de famille libanais fort
de son expérience se présente face à lui
le chef d'entreprise décide de lui
donner sa chance on a fait faire un
essai pour valider valider qui soit bien
qu'il soit bien dans le travail et il y
a pas de souci il a appelé plein de
compétences et aujourd'hui c'est des
compétences qu'on a besoin quoi
désemparé le patron exprime son
incompréhension il y a un système qui
fonctionne pas là il y a quelque chose
qui fonctionne pas qu'il faut qu'on
améliore oui ça c'est extrêmement
regrettable on a on a des personnes qui
sont prêtes à s'investir qui sont
arrivés en France qui ont le métier qui
savent travailler mais on peut pas les
embaucher parce qu'ils sont particuliers
ou ils ont pas un droit de séjour auprès
aux heures ou un droit de travail
provisoire quoi si le titre de séjour
métier en tension devait revenir au cœur
des débats la situation ne changerait
toutefois pas pour Joseph et sa famille
les boulangers n'étant pas concernés par
le dispositif
je vous présente tout de suite mes
invités Muriel Jourda bonsoir bien
soutenu vous êtes sénatrice LR du
Morbihan Mark ferrachi bonsoir bienvenue
député renaissance des Français de
l'étranger membre de la commission des
affaires sociales à l'Assemblée François
bienvenue à vous aussi vous êtes
professeur au Collège de France
titulaire de la chair la migration et
société vous publiez ce livre
immigration le grand déni aux éditions
du Seuil Mathieu croissanto évidemment
est resté à mes côtés vous venez de voir
notre reportage comment ça vous a Jourda
qu'a décolle intéressante c'est-à-dire
le boulanger prêt à embaucher cet
immigré libanais impossible parce qu'il
fait l'objet d'une auqtf il y a il y a
beaucoup de thèmes dans le thème
c'est-à-dire est-ce que par exemple moi
je commence par ça est-ce qu'on délivre
trop de qtf sur le territoire français
je pense que c'est vous prenez le
problème à l'envers le qtf c'est la
sanction d'un séjour irrégulier sur le
territoire français il me paraît pas
normal qu'un pays qui se définit par ses
frontières décide qui rentre et qui
reste sur son territoire donc on dérive
des octf parce qu'il y a des situations
de séjour irrégulières sur le territoire
donc vraiment les les faire respecter
c'est ça aussi la question alors c'est
peut-être
sortir encore une fois une politique
migratoire ça consiste effectivement à
définir qui rentre qui reste et pourquoi
ce qu'on ne fait pas d'ailleurs en
France pourquoi les gens rentreraient
donc il n'y a pas d'anormalité est-ce
que des gens qui sont pas en situation
régulière on leur demande de quitter le
territoire français
est-ce que la loi Darmanin du soft elle
permet où elle permettrait parce que on
va on va y revenir pour l'instant elle
est suspendue de répondre à ce type de
cases dilemme alors il y a dans cette
loi ou dans ces lois puisque vous savez
désormais qu'il y aura peut-être
plusieurs lois il y a une ambition qui
est à la fois de faire preuve de fermeté
notamment dans l'exécution des occultf
je réponds quand même sur le point
combien il y en a il y en a moins que
dans d'autres pays en particulier en
Allemagne en proportion de la population
donc on peut peut-être quand même se
poser la question est-ce que on en
délivre assez trop mais surtout dans
cette loi il y a un élément qui me
semble assez important qui est
d'introduire la possibilité pour les
travailleurs et c'était le cas de votre
de votre reportage qui se trouve en
situation régulière sachant que les
travailleurs qui sont en situation
régulière la plupart du temps ne sont
pas rentrés de manière clandestine ou de
manière irrégulière ils sont rentrés
bénéficiaires d'un titre de séjour qui a
expiré ça c'est la majeure partie des
gens qui sont en situation irrégulière
dans cette loi et bien il y a une
réponse qui s'appelle le titre de séjour
sur les métiers en tension qui devraient
permettre à des travailleurs d'initier
eux-mêmes et pas simplement avec
l'autorisation de leur employeur une
démarche de régularisation si ils
appartiennent à des métiers qui sont
identifiés comme expérimentant des
boulangerie soit
identifiée comme un métier en tension
écoutez ça vous posez une excellente
question c'est une question à laquelle
moi-même j'ai eu l'occasion d'essayer de
répondre quand j'étais au cabinet de la
ministre du Travail à l'époque ministre
Muriel Pénicaud se doter d'un outil à la
fois statistique et de remonter de
terrain dans les territoires pour savoir
ce que sont dans le Morbihan dans le
Grand Est les métiers qui sont en
tension et bien ça réclame un petit peu
de temps ça réclame un petit peu de
dialogue avec les parties prenantes il y
a justement une liste de métiers en
tension qui existe qui a été renouvelée
en avril 2021 qui va de nouveau faire
l'objet d'une d'une réflexion est-ce
qu'il y aura est-ce qu'il y a les
boulangers dans cette liste je n'en sais
rien mais c'est une question importante
et j'en termine justement avec la
réponse à votre question je pense qu'il
faut qu'on arrive à trouver un équilibre
entre cette fermeté cette fermeté
vis-à-vis notamment des personnes qui
sont en situation régulière et qui par
ailleurs ont commis des délits parce que
c'est aussi un élément du projet
d'armanin du socle et puis comment
est-ce qu'on fait pour intégrer des
personnes qui sont sur le territoire qui
travaillent dans des entreprises qui ont
besoin d'eux et bien je pense qu'il faut
qu'on arrive collectivement et en
essayant d'apaiser le débat autour de
tout ça parce qu'il y a parfois beaucoup
de passion dans le débat sur
l'immigration répondre de manière
pragmatique à cette question cet homme
qui qui fut des routes dévastée par
l'explosion du port par la crise
économique qui s'ensuit c'est assez
symbolique ou symptomatique même d'une
certaine façon François errant les flux
migratoires ils sont souvent liés à quoi
aux guerres
aux crises et il y a plusieurs est-ce
qu'une loi pour est-ce qu'une loi de
plus pour aller stopper
le plus augmenté dans le monde depuis
l'an 2000 mais aussi en France c'est les
étudiants internationaux ok de loin qui
a le plus augmenté il a fortement
augmenté dans le monde en France aussi
l'augmenter dans une proportion moindre
mais quand même importante à peu près de
50%. donc ça c'est la première grosse
augmentation il y a la migration de
travail qui est un peu augmenté en
France notamment parce que les
passeports talents ont été modifiés par
le premier quinquennat Macron ils
étaient plutôt réservés aux start-up au
patron de start-up ils ont été étendu
salariés des entreprises innovantes et
du coup il y a eu et c'est la première
fois parce que le programme
d'immigration choisi Nicolas Sarkozy a
totalement échoué il faut quand même le
rappeler ça fait un échec total on sait
jamais rapproché des objectifs qui a été
fixés par Nicolas Sarkozy sous Macron il
y a eu une augmentation de la migration
de travail qualifiée par les passeports
talents qui fait qu'on a commencé à se
rapprocher de ce que faisait pas mal de
pays européens en la matière et sur le
gros groupement familier attendez alors
le regroupe en familial alors il faut
faire il faut faire il y a là il y a des
titres familiaux à l'intérieur des
titres familiaux il y a le regroupement
familial qui est le droit pour un
étranger de de faire vivre de vivre avec
son conjoint avec ses enfants et il y a
aussi c'est autre chose le droit qu'un
Français ou une Française a d'épousé un
étranger ou étrangère ça c'est un droit
universel qu'on peut pas modifier quand
vous regardez le regroupement familial
ce tricotensus c'est 12.14 000 personnes
par an si vous regardez toute la
migration familiale
à des titres divers elle a été contenue
depuis une quinzaine d'années elle a
bais 4 % je ne comprends pas la fixation
d'une partie de la classe politique sur
la migration familiale qui alimenterait
comme ça les flux de façon sauvage un
contrôlable etc et les contrôlé parce
que finalement les 22 lois qui se sont
succédé depuis 1986 depuis la première
la loi Pasqua ont beaucoup ciblé la
migration familiale et on finit on va
ici à la contenir donc ce qui a augmenté
aussi c'est le refuge enfin ça c'est la
moindre des choses avec les événements
du Proche-Orient du Moyen-Orient depuis
2015 le monde des choses que et en gros
on en a accepté accepté un tiers des
demandes à peu près voilà les les
principales donc vous nous l'avez dit 22
lois en trois décennies est-ce qu'il
faut une loi de plus je mets un peu les
pieds dans le plat vous voyez le jour là
écoutez
il y a une certitude c'est que nous
n'arrivons pas à obtenir à atteindre les
objectifs qui sont fixés par les lois
qui sont à peu près toujours les mêmes
depuis un certain temps qui sont
maîtrisés les migrations et arriver à
intégrer les personnes étrangères qui
arrivent en France régulièrement donc il
faut vraisemblablement modifier quelque
chose moi ce qui meurt le plus dans
cette loi c'est que il y a des
dispositions qui se contredisent les
unes les autres
certaines qui effectivement sont faites
pour sans doute faire entrer une
immigration qui a plus de chance de
s'intégrer en fixant un niveau de langue
pour aussi permettre mais mon collègue
l'a dit tout à l'heure pour permettre
aussi d'éloigner plus facilement des
gens qui ont commis des infractions et
donc ils n'ont pas vocation à rester sur
le territoire français on les y
accueille il est évident que si en tout
cas à mes yeux que s'il commet des
infractions il n'a pas vocation est
resté en contrepartie on a un texte qui
est l'article 3 donc vous avez parlé
tout à l'heure qui est je crois un texte
qui anéantile mais l'idée même de droit
de donc c'est les métiers en tension
alors c'est pas les métiers en tension
c'est le fait que ce texte prévoit alors
pour une dure expérimentale jusqu'en
2026 que si vous avez passé trois ans en
France de façon irrégulière autrement on
a pas besoin d'être régularisé et que
vous êtes à 8 mois dans les 24 derniers
mois vous avez le droit d'obtenir un
titre jusqu'à maintenant comment ça se
passait la situation qu'on entend elle
existe depuis assez longtemps elle
bénéfait éventuellement de ce qu'on
appelle une mission exceptionnelle au
séjour c'est-à-dire que la personne qui
était en situation irrégulière forte
d'une attestation en quelque sorte de
son employeur aller dans une démarche
conjointe auprès du préfet sollicité son
admission exceptionnelle le séjour dans
le cadre d'un droit qui appartient à
tout un chacun qui est le droit à faire
examiner sa situation individuelle par
l'administration et le préfet alors dans
le cadre de la circulaire valse mais
deux manières générale le préfet
apprécier si oui ou non cette personne
avait le droit à rester aujourd'hui ce
qui est fait dans la nouvelle loi
que la fraude crée le droit c'est à dire
si vous avez fraudé suffisamment
longtemps et suffisamment habilement
pour ne pas être pris pendant trois ans
et bien le fait que cette fraude soit
établie va vous permettre d'obtenir un
titre opposable à l'administration le
préfet n'aura pas le choix ok Mathieu
vous poser une question qu'est-ce que ça
change ce qui sont là seront là
qu'est-ce que ça change ça change qu'en
réalité pourquoi faire des règles si le
fait de finalement ne pas les respecter
donne exactement les mêmes droits il
faut faire il faut faire la différence
entre entre le fait économique parce que
la plupart des gens qui travaillaient
qui étaient là et ils seront là demain
oui alors ça c'est une politique du fait
accompli que moi j'ai beaucoup de mal à
accepter c'est à dire que il m'apparaît
normal qu'un pays disque qui a le droit
d'entrer qui a le droit de rester je
crois que et le fait alors le fait que
vous disiez à quelqu'un entrer dans
n'importe quelle condition et vous aurez
le droit de rester sachant qu'on a plus
de texte sur l'immigration des réponses
ravis d'abord François Hero et ensuite
je vous vous avez une vision extrêmement
simpliste et complètement irréaliste de
la distinction entre le séjour régulier
de ce jour est régulier que les
personnes se retrouvent du côté régulier
régulier c'est extraordinairement
aléatoire vous prenez 10 militants
afghan moi j'en suis je les aide à
sortir de du pays si les vengeur
conseillent de choisir la voie régulière
s'ils prennent avoir régulière ça veut
dire qu'il faut évidemment acheter des
passeports pour toute la famille acheter
parce qu'ils sont pas délivrés
gratuitement par les autorités acheter
le passage à la frontière déposer une
demande au consulat français ça met
quatre mois avant d'avoir une réponse
avoir un entretien plus encore quatre
mois avant l'obtention éventuelle d'un
visa donc ça fait 8 mois de séjour à
Téhéran qu'il faut pouvoir payer si vous
n'êtes pas soutenu par un collectif ou
par des parents qui sont déjà installés
dans un pays européen c'est totalement
impossible donc la plupart de ces
militants des droits de l'homme de la
femme et des appartiennent à minorité à
Zara qui est incroyablement persécuté
etc et bien la plupart n'ayant passé
moyen se lance dans la voie irrégulière
ils arrivent à la frontière
franco-italienne ils sont refoulés par
la police ils reviennent deux fois trois
fois etc donc le le fait de se retrouver
sur le versant aiguillé ou irrégulier
est complètement aléatoire et ce que
beaucoup d'associations internationales
appellent silent lottery la loterie de
l'asile et donc l'idée est quand vous
regardez les titres de séjour qui ont
été délivrés pour les VPN vie privée vu
familiale qui n'est pas du regroupement
familial la famille est déjà là elle
démonte justement qu'il y a plus de
familles à l'extérieur que tout le monde
a ses attaches uniquement en France et
bien une enquête du ministère de
l'Intérieur donc est pas enquête
longitudinale sur l'intégration des
primo arrivants a montré que 40% des
personnes qui obtiennent ce titre
étaient déjà là il y a 9 ans donc au
moins 10 ans d'attente c'est pas de ça
tout à fait anormal et donc c'est ce
qu'on déclarait les ministres y compris
avec bedborne dans le débat sans vote à
l'Assemblée nationale et ensuite au
Sénat c'est qu'il y a des trappes à
pauvreté il y a des trappes de
vulnérabilité qui sont injustes parce
que ces personnes ont un travail donne
satisfaction leur employeur donne
satisfaction de la communauté locale
donc ces sons de l'estigatisé en disant
il n'y a pas deux espèces d'humanité
celle qui respecte les règles qui c'est
que les respectent pas il y a des
occultés légitimes ça c'est sûr mais il
y a un très grand nombre de qtf qui sont
complètement absurdes vous vouliez
prendre la parole évidemment ma ferrachi
peut-être je vais synthétiser une
critique qui est faite sur cet article 3
Le la critique de l'appel d'air c'est à
si on regularise c'est
c'est immigrés sans papier qui
travaillent en France depuis trois ans
et plus ça va créer un appel d'air alors
d'abord dire c'est je réponds à votre
question je vous l'assure mais d'abord
dire que cet article 3 je vais essayer
de nuancer un peu ce qu'a dit ma
collègue ils vise quand même à répondre
à au moins deux problèmes lourds que
nous connaissons puis un certain nombre
d'années le premier problème vous avez
évoqué la circulaire Valls qui est
aujourd'hui le cadre juridique dans
lequel s'opère des régularisations cette
circulaire elle est appliquée de manière
très différente suivant les endroits du
territoire suivant l'état d'esprit du
préfet suivant un certain nombre de
paramètres et ça crée au fond de
l'arbitraire ça crée des ruptures
d'égalité qui dans un cadre républicain
sont difficiles à accepter deuxième
problème auquel cette cet article vise à
répondre c'est qu'il y a aujourd'hui ça
n'était pas le cas dans votre reportage
mais il y a aujourd'hui beaucoup de
travailleurs qui ont atteint la fin de
leur titre de séjour qui sont en
situation régulière et qui continuent de
travailler parce que ils ont besoin de
vivre parce qu'ils sont contents d'être
en France mais aussi et surtout parce
que ils font face à des employeurs qui
sont dans une situation d'exploiter et
il faut le dire très clairement comme je
le disais tout à l'heure ce qui sera
rendu possible avec cet article c'est
pour le travailleur lui-même et pas pour
son employeur d'initier la démarche de
régularisation et moi je pense que c'est
un élément de progrès et dans cette loi
il y a des éléments de fermeté mais
d'eau s'il y avoir des éléments de
progrès sur lequel et bien on peut tous
se retrouver ensuite je vous entendais
dire que évidemment nous avons besoin de
contrôler notre immigration de contrôler
le nombre de gens qui entrent le nombre
de gens qui sortent le nombre de gens
qu'on expulse mais nous avons également
besoin d'avoir une forme de contrôle
plus qualitative si j'ose dire
c'est-à-dire se poser la question des
caractéristiques des gens qui rentrent
et ça c'est un élément sur lequel nous
travaillons d'ailleurs avec certains de
mes collègues députés que l'on retrouve
dans d'autres pays l'Allemagne vient de
présenter une loi visant à favoriser
l'immigration qualifiée aujourd'hui 29
mars en France nous le savons c'est bien
documenté par le Conseil d'analyse
économique notamment nous avons une
immigration qui est relativement peu
qualifiée et qui de mon point de vue on
peut ne pas partager ce point de vue
nourri dans l'opinion publique une
représentation négative de l'immigration
moi je pense qu'il faut qu'on assume et
bien de faire venir des gens qui sont
qualifiés de faire venir des gens qui
permettront d'illustrer les bénéfices de
l'immigration parce qu'ils existent et
ils sont réels et là aussi dérouler les
arguments
sur l'appel d'air très bien sur l'appel
d'air toujours pareil moi je suis je
suis universitaire de formation comme
Monsieur le Professeur errant j'aime
bien qu'on documente les choses je ne
connais aucune étude sérieuse qui
établit une relation de causalité entre
les mesures de régularisation qui ont
lieu sous tous les gouvernements de
gauche comme de droite dans les 10 20 30
dernières années et un appel d'air qu'on
puisse mesurer donc si vous avez des
éléments et des références je suis
preneur mais des travaux sérieux qui
document de cet appel d'air je n'en
connais pas je serais prêt à en discuter
si d'aventure il y avait ces éléments là
mais aujourd'hui aujourd'hui sincèrement
il n'y a rien alors atteste cela votre
avis là-dessus fait partie des arguments
donnés notamment par par les sénateurs
ou les députés et les raconter alors
vous n'avez pas entendu parler d'appel
d'air
pour moi cet article 3 c'est au-delà de
l'appel d'air c'est la négation même du
droit de l'immigration alors qu'on
veuille et de et de du choix pays de
faire venir ou pas sur leur territoire
des étrangers
que l'on va y avoir une immigration
qualifiée je trouve ça plutôt de bonne
aloi je ne suis pas en désaccord avec
mon collègue député sauf qu'il n'y a
rien de ce style dans ce texte de loi
là pour moi l'angle mort de la politique
migratoire en France et qu'il n'y en a
pas c'est à dire que on sait très bien
comment on rentre on sait très bien que
quels sont les procédures pour quelles
raisons on peut rentrer on sait très
bien comment on peut faire sentir les
gens même si clairement on y arrive pas
mais on dit pas pourquoi on accepte que
des personnes viennent sur le territoire
indépendamment évidemment de l'aspect
humanitaire mais c'est une partie de
l'immigration l'immigration humaine
d'une certaine façon on le dit si on dit
on a des secteurs économiques qui ont
besoin de de salariés de force de
travail et donc on les accueille à votre
question alors non on dit pas qu'on les
accueille on dit qu'une fois qu'ils sont
là qui nous ont mis devant le fait
accompli avoir frauder après avoir
fraudé pendant trois ans là on va les
régulariser on va leur donner des droits
je rappelle quand même qu'il existe des
titres qui de faire entrer en France des
gens pour travailler ça existe on peut
aussi faire entrer des gens légalement
je ne suis pas opposé à toute
immigration l'immigration de travail ne
me paraît pas de mauvaise à loi mais je
souhaite tout de même qu'elle soit
régulière et qu'elle soit décidée en
amont et pas mis devant accompli tout à
l'heure sur régulateur régularité
régularité n'a absolument y'a aucun
effet si madame la sénatrice c'est oui
parce que en réalité la réalité des
choses infiniment plus complexe cette
dichotomie que vous établissez entre
irréguliers et non réguliers vous avez
un nombre important de personnes en
situation en rigueur qui sont passées
par une situation irrégulière c'est
c'est absolument et je voudrais revenir
sur ce qu'a dit Monsieur le Député
c'est-à-dire que effectivement
actuellement il y a la circulaire Valls
qui n'a pas une valeur impérative qu'on
a je vais vous interrompre je voudrais
que le débat avance
très important c'est la rupture la
question c'est la rue un peu têtu mais
c'est quand même la rupture d'égalité
entre les territoires oui mais pas
normal qu'un préfet décide si oui ou non
la raison pour laquelle ils font ça
c'est que les effectifs des
les postes en préfecture en
sous-préfecture en baissé 14 % en disant
c'est un rapport de la Cour des comptes
qu'il a montré et donc du coup le faute
de de d'agence spécialisée du Mont formé
pour voir traiter ces questions là des
préfets décident de leur propre chef de
ne pas appliquer régularisation égale à
l'appel d'air c'est un effectivement
est-ce que le document de passe il n'y a
pas eu de démonstration là-dessus la
plus grande régularisation qu'on est
connue dans l'histoire c'est Regan 1986
c'était absolument considérable et on
n'a pas eu d'effet massifs le ce qui
s'est passé ensuite dépend de la
conjoncture économique beaucoup plus que
des régularisations je crois que il y a
un mythe là-dessus c'est vous comprenez
c'est c'est de la peur on a peur mais
mais cette peur elle est imprécise elle
est un peu fantomatique mais c'est vrai
qu'on manque de données pour établir
tous alors on va parler maintenant de du
destin de l'avenir de cette loi
immigration je propose à Jonathan du
prix et de nous rejoindre sur ce plateau
rebonsoir Jonathan donc elle était
censée cette loi immigration être
examinée cette semaines en primeur au
Sénat
peut-être dire maintenant que c'est pas
près de voir le jour c'est ça mais c'est
en tout cas le risque Thomas parce que
Emmanuel Macron on le sait il est quand
même en Pétré dans la réforme des
retraites et politiquement en ce moment
assez en difficulté et donc Emmanuel
Macron il a décidé de reporter la
semaine dernière son projet de loi
immigration Gérard Larcher le président
du Sénat lui avait soufflé l'idée à
l'oreille estimant qu'il fallait je le
cite des conditions apaisées pour
débattre de ce sujet sensible et on
comprend bien la logique dans ce
contexte de grande tension sociale sauf
qu'au lieu d'une simple modification de
calendrier et bien Emmanuel Macron est
allé plus loin en prenant non pas un
seul mais plusieurs textes immigration
dans les prochaines semaines et donc le
mot qu'on emploie souvent depuis
quelques jours c'est saucissonner le
gouvernement voudrait saucissonner ce
texte pour le faire passer plus
facilement c'est ça et en tout cas ce
serait pour des raisons politiques le
ministère de l'Intérieur en tout cas
laisse entendre que ça pourrait être
deux voir peut-être trois textes avec un
premier projet de loi
issus du gouvernement inspiré du
rapporteur François Noel buffet du
rapport de François Nouel buffet qui est
le président de la commission des lois
ici donc ça ce serait pour les mesures
on va dire les plus techniques
consensuel d'un simplification notamment
des procédures de demande d'asile il
pourrait y en avoir un deuxième plus
coercitif
issu de LR pourquoi pas sur
l'éloignement des étrangers délinquants
par exemple ou l'application la
meilleure application des auqtf et
peut-être un troisième
issu de la majorité présidentielle qui
pourrait pourquoi pas convenir à la
gauche cette fois-ci sur l'intégration
des étrangers par la langue et le
travail en prenant pourquoi pas le titre
séjour le titre séjour métier en tension
mais ici au Sénat en tout cas les
groupes politiques quels qu'ils soient
n'en veulent pas en ces termes ils
veulent pas un texte à la découpe
écoutez ce qu'on disait le patron des
sénateurs et l'herbe Bruno Retailleau
pour la loi de régularisation notamment
l'article 3 qui crée un titre de séjour
de régularisation sur les métiers en
tension là j'imagine qu'ils vont aller
rechercher l'appui de la gauche à
l'Assemblée nationale les pays pour un
Cerdon de procédure un peu plus
contraignant la pluie à droite mais ça
peut pas marcher comme ça il n'y aura
pas notre soutien ni nous ni à
l'Assemblée nationale en réalité sur ce
genre de texte à la découpe ce texte qui
se veut équilibrer qui devait contenter
la droite et la gauche il va peut-être
finir par mécontentrer tout le monde
mais ouais ça va peut-être fâché tout le
monde car même en saucissonnant ces
textes pour trouver des majorités
opportunistes tantôt à droite sur un
volet du texte tantôt à gauche sur un
autre ben le gouvernement pourrait
peiner à convaincre les oppositions sur
ce projet avoir une majorité chez les
socialistes par exemple on se méfie
beaucoup de ce fameux texte sur le volet
intégration par le travail pour la
simple et très bonne raison qu'il serait
inutile selon plusieurs parlementaires
de légiférer alors que la voie
réglementaire pourrait parfois suffire à
écouter le sénateur Jean-Yves Leconte
qu'elle sait le chef de fil des
socialistes sur l'immigration
ce qui est vrai c'est que sur les
questions de travail si le gouvernement
veut vraiment faire des choses il peut
les faire sans texte législatif parce
que que ce soit sur le texte la liste
des métiers en tension que ce soit sur
l'administration l'admission
exceptionnelle au séjour en particulier
pour les personnes qui travaillent que
ce soit pour le le droit au travail de
demandeur d'asile de pouvoir
réglementaire a déjà tout en main pour
avancer
et le gouvernement aussi va devoir
composer avec les dissensions au sein de
LR qui a ce stade s'échappe sur le futur
texte qui veulent porter le Sénat une
ligne peut-être plus dur que l'Assemblée
nationale et il y a quelques jours le
patron des députés Olivier Marleix a
annoncé d'ailleurs c'était sur notre
antenne qu'il allait déposer avec Éric
Ciotti une proposition de loi sur les
questions migratoires il joue au con on
m'a glissé tout à l'heure un sénateur de
droite dans les couloirs les sénateurs
ils avaient pas été mis au courant de
cette proposition d'Olivier Marleix
merci beaucoup Jonathan du priez ce
saucissonnage Muriel Jourdain vous y
êtes opposé pourquoi oui je pense que ça
n'a pas beaucoup de sens parce que une
politique elle s'apprécie en son
ensemble son ensemble et
je ne suis pas sûr de le gouvernement
aura ce type de démarche qui était un
peu puéril de penser que personne ne
verra
l'autre texte qui suit ou qui précède et
qui ne sera pas du goût de tout le monde
faire un texte plutôt de droite un texte
plutôt de gauche et un texte plutôt de
procédure bon ça me paraît pas
raisonnable en tout cas Bruno Retailleau
l'a indiqué et c'est le cas
votre collègue de tous les groupes au
Sénat on acceptera pas de de trancher
sur trois lois alors que c'est une seule
qu'il nous faut
les jardins à la française des lois
globales équilibrées qui traite tous les
sujets en même temps je le dis
franchement même si on en a déjà fait 22
ans vous savez l'immigration ça a été
décrit ce sont des phénomènes qui
évoluent dans le temps il est pas normal
qu'on prenne des législations
successives mais à un moment par rapport
à cette logique qui était d'ailleurs la
logique initiale les deux ministres ont
présenté l'ensemble des dispositions
dans une interview au Monde et moi je
mets cette présentation parce qu'elle
donnait justement le sentiment d'un
équilibre maintenant il faut être
réaliste il faut être réaliste et
notamment prendre en compte qu'est la
réalité de la configuration n'ont pas au
Sénat vous disposez d'une majorité
solide le groupe les républicains mais à
l'Assemblée nationale la réalité de la
majorité relative à l'Assemblée
nationale nous oblige à trouver des
compromis et on voit bien que une loi
est équilibré sur le volet fermeté et
sur le volet humanité donne en réalité
les arguments à la gauche et à la droite
de ne pas la voter c'est la raison pour
laquelle on parle de saucissonnage c'est
un petit peu c'est un peu dépréciatif
moi je pense que on peut avoir de texte
peut-être plus j'en sais rien mais en
tout cas deux textes qui manifestent une
identité politique claire qui font
l'objet d'annonce sur ce que sera le
texte suivant et qui au fond permettent
de trouver ces majorités ces compromis
parce que une voix qui est une loi qui
n'est pas adoptée elle peut être
formidable sur le papier mais à la main
un moment elle ne sert à rien vous dites
que les enjeux ont évolué avec les
années c'est ce qui explique le nombre
de lois en tout cas les solutions n'ont
pas forcément évolué quand on regarde ce
qui est demandé raccourcir les délais du
droit d'asile tout le monde le demande
depuis 20 ans
mieux mieux faire réaliser les auqtf
Manuel Valls François Hollande ne
demandait il y a 10 ans mais de la
maîtrise du français qui est aussi
brandie pour comme un facteur
d'intégration même la loi portefeu en
2007 le demander pourquoi on y arrive
jamais
ça c'est une question dans la réponse se
trouve ou pas dans les multiples
rapports d'évaluation des lois en
question je pense que toutes les lois
tout cas tout celles que j'ai en mémoire
on va essayer de marcher sur ces deux
jambes parfois marcher sur deux jambes
c'est trouver des solutions qui ne sont
ambitieuses ni sur l'une ni sur l'autre
et je prends l'exemple du fameux titre
de séjour métier en tension quand vous
discutez avec des associations qui
travaillent au contact des immigrés des
associations qui travaillent pas
forcément aller régulariser mais à les
accompagner à les intégrer par le
travail et vous explique que cette
mesure là c'est une mesure qu'ils
attendent depuis des années précisément
pour les gens que j'ai indiqué tout à
l'heure et sur lesquels je vais pas
revenir donc moi je fais pas le bilan ni
le procès des législations précédentes
je dis que dans cette loi il y a des
mesures dont je pense qu'elles sont
puissantes pour régler les problèmes que
nous avons ensuite je veux simplement
terminer en répondant à ce point qui est
un point de convergence je pense avec ma
collègue sénatrice c'est que à un moment
il faut qu'on assume avec l'idée
d'immigration qualifiée le fait que
beaucoup de pays dans le monde cherchent
des talent et quand vous dites qu'il n'y
a rien dans cette loi qui favorise
véritablement l'immigration qualifiée
j'ai envie de vous dire à ce stade c'est
vrai à ce stade c'est vrai et c'est la
raison pour laquelle je pense que nous
devons améliorer cette loi nous
travaillons avec des collègues députés à
l'idée d'un permis à point l'idée d'un
permis à point inspiré de ce qui se fait
au Canada inspirer de ce qui se fait en
Allemagne qui serait cantonneux à
l'immigration qualifiée quand on est à
l'immigration qualifiée qui permettrait
au fond d'envoyer un signal
d'attractivité à ces gens qui peuvent
choisir le pays dans lequel ils vont
travailler parce que justement ils ont
des diplômes je pense qu'il faut qu'on
se dote de ce genre d'outils nous allons
je l'espère en discuter au Parlement
votre avis sur ce permis à point en
quelque sorte mais le permis a point
effectivement c'est une sorte de
concours de capital humain qui avait été
inventé par les Canadiens ça n'a marché
qu'à moitié parce que les provinces
elles voulaient pouvoir confronter
l'offre et la demande et on demandait un
système qui est l'équivalent des métiers
en tension donc actuellement au Canada
il y a un mélange il y a un mélange
c'est l'État fédéral qui fait le système
à points et les provinces cherchent à
tirer les migrants en tenant compte de
l'état du marché du travail on est dans
un système mixte mais moi je voudrais
dire que et d'ailleurs Gérald Darmanin a
dit on a des besoins à tous les niveaux
de planification il a cité les ouvriers
agricoles pendant le covid les
producteurs Corse ont obtenu de l'Office
le droit d'organiser un pont aérien pour
qu'on puisse les travailleurs marocains
puissent récolter les fruits on a besoin
on a on a besoin de personnels dans les
hôpitaux à tous les niveaux de
qualification l'idée que on aurait que
la migration qualifiée me paraît un peu
irréaliste parce que
c'est pas une solution qui est
généralisable si tous les pays
adoptaient ça que se passerait-il enfin
nous avons des besoins à tous les
niveaux de qualification je crois qu'il
est important de le de le dire alors je
voudrais revenir sur les
occuts les les arrêter de reconduite à
la frontière lors de son audition devant
le la commission des Lois du Sénat donc
c'était en préparation du texte qui
devait être examiné en séance plénière
aujourd'hui le milieu de l'Intérieur
pointait le trop grand nombre de recours
possible écoutez
qu'est-ce qui se passe la plupart du
temps lorsque un préfet prend un arrêté
de reconduite à la frontière enfin le
fameux Qt désormais bien connu je crois
par une partie de nos compatriotes des
recours sans cesse peuvent être formulés
mais entre-temps depuis deux ans que
c'est contentieux existent à l'étranger
a pu soit trouver un travail de façon
illégale et parfois de toute façon
légale le ministre du Travail il
reviendra notre propre incurie
administrative ou de la part de
personnes employeur voyou il a pu se
marier avoir en tout cas des relations
juridiques on va dire sur le territoire
de la République avoir des enfants les
inscrire à l'école et donc au bout d'un
moment la vie privée est familiale fait
que le temps a joué contre la décision
originale de l'État et parce que nous
n'avons pas été vite et parce que les
contentieux sont trop nombreux on en est
à des situations improbables
il faut réduire le nombre de recours
possible alors pour le coup les
procédures a été réduites on est passé
de 12 ou 13 procédures à alors trois
dans le rapport du Conseil d'État 4
aujourd'hui dans le projet de loi du
gouvernement mais le nombre de recours
la simplification des recours oui elle
doit exister bien sûr si la loi passe si
la loi passe mais si la rue passe mais
c'est un sujet sur lequel nous ne sommes
pas tout à fait d'accord à un recours
prêt avec le gouvernement mais c'est un
sujet sur lequel il a été indiqué tout à
l'heure le président François el buffet
avait déposé un texte voilà c'est une
proposition du Conseil d'État qui est
très procédurale donc ça n'a pas de je
dirais que ça n'a pas il n'y a pas de
d'enjeu politique sur la question ça
facilite les choses ça ne fera pas
diminuer le nombre de cas en quelque
sorte mais ça facilitera les choses et
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à François
Hollande continue nous dit que
finalement de toute façon là quoi la
demande économique elle est là elle est
pas seulement pour des immigrés
qualifiés mais je lui répondrais que le
taux de de
chômage des personnes étrangères en
France et de plus de 15 donc nous avons
déjà me semble-t-il sur le territoire
des gens qui sont en situation régulière
qui si on connaît leur taux de chômage
sont inscrits à Pôle Emploi ça veut dire
qu'il bénéficient d'une autorisation de
travailler et qu'on est autant
susceptible de former à ces métiers qui
ne sont peut-être pas très qualifiés
mais qui nécessitent tout de même une
formation que ceux qui viendraient de
l'étranger donc on a déjà ça et je
rappelle que Pôle Emploi un programme
qui s'appelle programme sésame qui
prévoit de former les personnes primo
arrivantes pour l'hôtellerie qui a fait
restauration donc on il y a déjà
je pense des personnes qui sont là et
qui peuvent être formées et il y a déjà
des plans de formation moi je demande à
ce qu'on mette en place qui existe et il
y a en plus et mon collègue députés qui
s'en est occupé connaît très bien un
texte qui était bien d'application je
crois depuis le mois dernier de enfin
depuis février sur l'assurance chômage
qui prévoit certains notes de choses
pour permettre aussi que les personnes
qui sont au chômage lorsqu'on est dans
une situation de métier en tension et
bien plus arriver un peu plus rapidement
qu'elle ne le souhaiterait peut-être
vers le travail donc on a déjà en France
des dispositifs qu'il s'agisse de
chômeurs étrangers ou français qu'il
faudrait peut-être mettre en oeuvre
avant de faire venir une main d'oeuvre
qui de l'étranger sauf que le secteur
que vous avez cité hôtellerie
restauration café etc ne passe très peu
par Pôle emploi pour pour l'emploi ne
lui donne pas les les personnes
nécessaires et en fait la plupart des
métiers qui sont deux faits en tension
ne passe pas par Pôle emploi et c'est
tout le problème d'ailleurs de
l'indicateur statistique qu'on a été
obligé d'ailleurs de modifier en 2017
pour inclure des demandes qui ne passent
pas par Pôle emploi et maintenant
l'indicateur est prend en compte à 50%
vous connaissez cette affaire très bien
et même ferrachi
les demandes des employeurs la la
position des employeurs sur le caractère
en tension ou pas de leur propre secteur
et là on imite un peu ce qui se passe en
Suisse ou effectivement le système des
métiers en tension existe depuis les
années 70 avec des évaluations très très
intéressantes mais ça ne se passe ça ne
se fait pas par des indicateurs formels
comme ça statistiques d'en haut ce sont
les commissions triparties où il y a des
syndicalistes des des entrepreneurs des
évidemment des responsables locaux etc
qui Pargent par canton arrive à
identifier les métiers en tension et ça
c'est une formule évidemment beaucoup
plus
opérative que le doctrine enfin la
doctrine très dogmatique qui est
actuellement professionnelle par la
droite sénatoriale Matthieu vouliez
revenir aux racines du macronisme en
matière d'immigration
qui a dit contrairement à ce que
certains disent nous ne sommes pas
confrontés à une vague d'immigration le
sujet de l'immigration ne devrait pas
inquiéter la population française
l'immigration fait partie du monde dans
lequel nous vivons de surcroît
l'immigration se révèle être une chance
d'un point de vue économique culturel et
social vous me voyez venir c'était
manuel Macron nous étions alors le 2
mars 2017 et le candidat en marche
accordé un entretien mené par la
présidente de la au magazine protestant
réforme c'est un petit événement à
l'époque car jusqu'à présent enfin
jusqu'à lors Emmanuel Macron n'avait pas
dit un mot d'immigration ou presque dans
sa campagne ça figure même pas dans le
programme qui était distribué dans les
boîtes à lettres des Français maintenant
penchons-nous si vous voulez sur
l'exposé des motifs de la loi
immigration depuis 20 ans les flumées
d'un toit s'accélèrent dans toute
l'Europe il est nécessaire de regarder
cette réalité peut-on y lire dès les
premières phrases on y parle de pression
migratoire particulièrement marquée on y
part de la part des étrangers dans la
délinquance on se fixe comme objectif
notamment de contrôler l'immigration de
lever les freins et l'éloignement
j'arrête là vous avez compris c'est
quand même un sacré salto arrière et
alors comment vous l'expliquez en fait
la vision de l'immigration qui va nous
Macron défend en 2017 elle relève à la
fois de l'impensé et du choix tactique
impensé parce que ce sujet ne figure pas
dans le cœur du logiciel macroniste et
puis je souhaite tactique parce qu'à
l'époque il s'agit pour le candidat de
se démarquer radicalement sa principale
adversaire qui est Marine Le Pen alors
ce choix d'Emmanuel Macron parmi
d'autres se révèlera payant parce que il
Clive et il achève de séduire ou en tout
cas d'amadouer les derniers électeurs de
gauche réticents qui voyaient surtout en
lui un ancien banquier plutôt qu'un
authentique progressiste mais cette lune
de miel elle va pas durer très longtemps
dès 2018 Emmanuel Macron qui avait
appelé au lendemain de son élection à
accueillir des réfugiés car c'est notre
tradition et notre honneur va décevoir
puis
ulcérer un très grand nombre
d'associations de ONG d'organisation
caritative
à cause du sort qu'il réserve aux
migrants ces associations dénonce le
refoulement aux frontières la
criminalisation des bénévoles le
démontage des gants brutal l'heure est à
l'époque à l'immigration maîtrisée le
temps a changé et c'est le migration
maîtrisée et l'intégration ici c'est
d'ailleurs le titre de la loi colon qui
sera promulgué le 10 septembre 2018 et
ça traduit quoi mais ça se traduit en
matière d'immigration le macronisme est
un pragmatisme qui ne semble qui ne
s'embarrasse guère quand ça l'arrange de
cohérence l'idéologie mais qui n'oublie
pas les procuations électoralistes les
exemples sont nombreux on l'a vu on
pourrait ajouter la question des quotas
par exemple qui était jugé inapplicable
par le en 2017 parce que impossible à
faire respecter et puis qu'ensuite était
défendu par son gouvernement en 2019 il
est vrai que l'objectif à l'époque
c'était plus de séduire la gauche qu'il
avait éparpillé façon puzz mais plutôt
de triangulaire à droite et puis alors
là 2023 nous on virage dans une
assemblée sans majorité on y fait
référence tout à l'heure le président
tente le projet de loi bicolore un coup
à droite pour le durcissement du
contrôle migratoire merci l'armadin un
coup à gauche pour la régularisation
expérimentale des sans-papiers dans les
secteurs en tension merci du soft subtil
un peu trop sans doute qu'est-ce que
vous dites Marc Ferracci quand vous
justifiez ce salto arrière du président
je vais essayer de répondre à la charge
de Mathieu croissanto avec le talent
qu'on lui connaît il y avait avec avec
la verve qu'on lui connaît
dans ce qui était dit en 2017 l'idée
qu'il y a des bénéfices et l'immigration
il n'y a aucune remise en question quand
je vous parlais tout à l'heure de ce
qu'on sait aujourd'hui de l'impact de
l'immigration à court et à moyen terme
sur la prospérité et la croissance
économique ce sont des choses qui sont
assumées et qui restent assumer par ce
gouvernement et par cette majorité
présidentielle il y a pas de remise en
question et d'ailleurs ce qu'on a évoqué
je vais pas y revenir sur la partie
travail immigration économique de la loi
immigration dont on discute et bien
témoigne du fait que on sait je reprends
les mots transférents que on nous avons
des besoins nous avons des besoins parce
que nous savons et c'est aussi le sens
des propos d'Emmanuel Macron que la
représentation
du marché du travail comme celle d'un
gâteau qui se partagerait de taille fixe
de taille fixe est une représentation
parfaitement erronée et c'est ce que
disent toutes les études qui montrent
que quand des immigrés arrivent on l'a
vu avec les répatriés d'Algérie il y a
une étude assez connue là-dessus on l'a
vu avec l'exode de Marielle les Cubains
qui sont allés en Floride ça n'a aucun
effet négatif sur le salaire ni sur
l'emploi des natifs et ça c'est une
c'est un c'est un point fixe vous parlez
zigzag je veux rappeler qu'il y a ce
point fixe le point fixe il est très
important ensuite ensuite là où je vous
rejoins c'est que la parole du président
et les évolutions législatives qu'on a
connues ces dernières années avec la loi
colon avec une partie de la loi
d'armanin du sot et bien tienne compte
de fait sociaux de la sensibilité mais
aussi de réalité en matière
d'immigration le fait que les auqtf
mettent du temps à être exécutés c'est
quelque chose que nous concitoyens
n'acceptent pas n'accepte plus en tout
cas
ont du mal ont du mal à à accepter et
donc on en tient compte mais on en tient
de l'opportunisme politique qui tient
compte de la droitisation d'une partie
de la société française la droitisation
vous savez si on regarde les élections
depuis 30 ans elle n'est pas en réalité
très récente du point de vue de du
barycentre j'ai envie de dire de
l'échiquier politique donc je pense que
je pense qu'il y a aussi et j'en termine
avec ça il y a aussi on a souvent
reproché au présent Macron de pas être à
l'écoute d'être dans son château dans sa
tour d'ivoire il y a aussi énormément
des lutins des députés dans leur
circonscription des sénateurs nous en
avons quand même quelques-uns au Sénat
de la majorité des élus émerres qu'il
rencontre que nous rencontrons tous qui
nous font remonter ces préoccupations à
la fois les besoins de recrutement les
métiers en tension qui lisent attendez
aidez-nous on a besoin de régulariser
certains de nos de nos travailleurs
immigrés qui sont à Paris ou leur titre
de séjour et en même temps en même temps
ce sentiment que et bien il y a
effectivement un peu de dépossession
mais il faut lutter contre ça et c'est
pour ça moi je reviens là-dessus il faut
arriver a changé la représentation de
l'objet non publique sur l'immigration
je pense qu'il faut avoir une approche
peut-être plus volontariste que nous
l'avons aujourd'hui sur l'immigrations
qualifiées dernier thème il nous reste
quelques minutes dans dans on a appris
aujourd'hui grâce à nos confrères du
monde que le gouvernement s'apprête à
ouvrir des SAS d'hébergement temporaires
en région pour mieux orienter les
personnes migrantes qui sont à la rue en
Île-de-France les envoyer en dehors de
l'Île-de-France d'après ministère de
l'Intérieur 500 places devraient être
ouvertes dont les premières courants
avril répartis dans 10 régions dites
quoi bonne idée vous dites c'est
toujours extrêmement compliqué
on l'avait vu assez récemment avec
Saint-Brevin souvent ça se fait sans
beaucoup de concertation
les populations sont un peu inquiète à
Toro a raison mais il est vrai que on
parle beaucoup d'économies ici mais
il y a certains certaines nationalités
d'étrangers dont les la vie les mœurs la
culture sont tout à fait différentes des
nôtres et on ne peut pas ne pas entendre
que ça peut un peu inquiéter la
population parce qu'on le voit dans dans
certains
villes de France ou la cohabitation est
difficile donc le risque de
communautarisme alors le risque du
communautarisme il est avéré en France
donc ce que vous nous décrivez tout à
fait il y a un risque du communautarisme
qui va totalement à l'inverse de
l'universalisme français qui est
qu'effectivement on finit par se définir
pas par des mœurs encore une fois et par
une vie qui n'est pas celle qu'on peut
connaître en France
que que d'autres je pense que par
exemple les pays subsahariens ont des
modes de vie donc très différents des
nôtres je pense que des populations ou
la charia s'applique et où les gens
connaissent la charia depuis longtemps
c'est-à-dire la règle religieuse qui
régit votre quotidien la loi civile la
loi pénale ils ne vont pas acquérir par
capillarité en posant le pied sur le sol
français là la laïcité qui est quelque
chose d'extrêmement important en France
mais qui est totalement opposé aux
règles qui régissent certains pays donc
ça peut effectivement poser difficulté
je pense qu'il y a des pays dans
lesquels les femmes ne sont pas
extrêmement considérées et ça les
parents en France que les hommes qui ne
considèrent pas les femmes vont
apprendre parce qu'ils vont arriver en
France que les femmes sont à considérer
parce que l'égalité homme-femme c'est
extrêmement important donc il y a des
vrais préoccupations qui correspondent à
des réalités des réalités on ne vit pas
tous dans le monde de la même façon et
quand tu as un morceau du monde vient
chez vous qui ne vit pas de cette façon
là et que on crée des petites enclaves
de gens qui ne vont pas s'intégrer parce
qu'ils vont assez naturellement c'est
mal gamises qui est logique on fera la
même chose ça peut bien sûr causer des
difficultés avec la population il y a
pas qu'un aspect économique dans
l'immigration un mot de réponse
là-dessus pour conclure mais écoutez
dans les années 30 dans les années 20 on
craignait que les Espagnols que les
Polonais fait forment des enclaves des
groupes halogènes des etc c'était le la
crainte bon finalement ils se sont
intégrés et ce qu'on observe et ça c'est
une enquête récent de Lindsay lyded
c'est que les mariages mixtes
progressent y compris avec les personnes
originaires du Maghreb très fortement et
au bout de deux de trois générations les
choses évoluent donc ne figeons pas les
situations actuelles d'autant que
beaucoup de militants qui sont venus
chez nous fuir la Syrie l'Irak c'est
juste pour protester contre les
législations et les mœurs dans la parole
c'est je pense assez d'une façon assez
équilibrée
dispersée sur ce plateau merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat j'ai
rappelé François Iran le titre de votre
livre immigration le grand déni qui est
publié aux éditions du Seuil voilà je
vous dis à demain pour un nouveau numéro
de sens public et piloter votre prochain
rendez-vous prochaine invité politique
dans la matinale Stéphane Le Foll
l'ancien ministre et mère socialiste du
Mans il sera face à Oriane à 8 heures du
matin belle soirée